it is so wonderful to see you i mean
last time we saw each other was
virtually
on diwali and how are you how are you
coping and how are the kids enjoying
virtual school
all of that oh well you know it's it's
like everyone
we're really looking forward to getting
through this uh with uh vaccinations
coming and everyone getting vaccinated
uh we're definitely in line for a much
better summer
uh but we still have to hang on and uh
you know there's still
not enough uh sleepovers or birthday
parties that is still none uh
for the kids but uh we're uh we're
looking forward to a much better outdoor
summer
i love that you know and i just want to
say thank you for being part of this
because it's so important to me that we
are actually doing this special
to help the humanitarian crisis in india
and when you think about it
there's so much we can do and so what
are the steps canada
is doing to help india at this very
difficult time
well first of all i mean we've seen it
throughout this pandemic
uh canadians have stepped up to be there
for each other to be there for people
around the world to be there for their
neighbors
like we we understand that we don't get
through this unless we all get through
this together and that's where
uh it's really been heartwarming to see
the number of people step
up to donate through the canadian red
cross to the uh to the indian red cross
uh whether it's uh engaged in in in
supporting family members or friends
back home or the canadian government we
stepped up with 10
10 million dollars and have sent both
therapeutics and ventilators and
shipments of equipment
uh to india because we know uh what a
devastating situation it is but we also
know
this pandemic doesn't end anywhere until
it ends everywhere
when you hear about the staggering
numbers and the cases there it
it's unbelievable and how many people
are dying because of lack of oxygen i
mean
when you hear that and you what goes
through your mind
knowing that people are losing their
lives because of oxygen supply
well first of all it's well what can we
do to help because yes
even as we are facing challenges
with certain parts of the country much
higher caseloads than we'd want and
icu's
getting to their limits uh we still have
ways that we need to look to help
out others around the world nobody wants
to see just the terrible images and the
tragedies
uh that we're hearing from loved ones
and family members
for those who have family there it is it
is just heartbreaking
and even as we're going through
difficult times uh you know canadians
are always there to think about
others who are facing difficult times
and and that's something that is
i think even amidst all the tragedy
really hopeful for the kind of world
that we're gonna you know come into
through this this dark time now you went
to india a few years ago you got to
experience it firsthand what did you
learn about the culture the people
the experience oh i you know i i've
got to travel to india a few times in my
life and when i was uh
younger when i was backpacking and uh
more recently as well and and you know
it's always about the people for me
uh incredibly uh warm generous
engaged uh optimistic about the future
just this vibrancy of of different
cultures of different perspectives
uh it really is a place that i mean i
we always laugh that canada and india
are the world's two largest democracies
uh ours by geography uh and india by
population and i think there's a there's
a connection there
uh that means that in these difficult
times uh we need to be there for each
other
when you think of india what does it
represent to you
um it represents so much of
both the challenges of the 21st century
and the opportunities of the 21st
century i mean there are
tremendous income disparities uh but you
know tremendous potential at the same
time
uh there are people who live off the
land a strong agricultural community
but there's also a lot of technology
there's
there's all these all these contrasts
and again
the diversity the range of languages of
backgrounds of cultures
uh coming together i mean the challenge
we have as a 21st century is to figure
out how to make diversity and
differences
a source of strength not a source of
fault lines or weaknesses and
canada does that better than just about
any other country in the world
but it's something that we can always
think about how we
encourage and engage with others who are
who are struggling and trying to do the
same
now over a year ago uh we were just
learning about this virus and your wife
got tested positive
as a husband as a father the unknowns
what
what was going through your mind at that
time well it made it it made it
really real for for me but i know for a
lot of canadians as well
seeing sophie get it uh and us going to
lock down at the same time
as the country was sort of going okay
maybe we should all go into lockdown
yeah it just it crystallized a lot of
the the thinking and yes it was
it was tough and and you know she you
know she was she was sick she wasn't
hospitalized but it's
it's no fun for everyone who's had uh
even a a a mild or moderate case of
covid it's it's no fun uh let it let
alone the
the tragedies that have come with it uh
but we we made it through
and we you know got to canadians take it
very
seriously and i think that was one of
the reasons why
you know through the through the time
that the success of that first lockdown
allowed us all uh to you know
i think do pretty well through this uh
this pandemic yes
far too many tragedies particularly in
long-term care homes and
in uh in in minority communities and in
lower income communities which
means we have a lot of gaps we still
have to address
but i think in general canadians pulling
together and taking this seriously
avoided some of the political fights
that slowed down the us's approach last
year
uh and and really showcased the best of
who canadians are
and just recently you and your wife got
your shot your first shot uh
on her birthday of all days uh did you
feel a sense of relief
and joy you know it's amazing because we
were talking about how
important it was for everyone to get
vaccinated what a big deal it was to get
vaccinated so
i thought that was all built in already
but
getting that shot really was an amazing
feeling it it it hits you did you cry
i cry you know i cry at movies i didn't
cry at the
at the shot but you know it was a moment
where
where you realize okay this is it and it
wasn't so much
because i felt that i'm at high risk
because we're being careful and i'm
healthy and i'm young and all that
but at the same time it's knowing that
each of us doing our part is
getting through this because we don't
get through this unless you know the
vast majority of the population
gets that first shot and then a few
months later gets that second shot
that's how we get through it and it's
something that everyone can do and we're
just seeing
canadians come out in such strong
numbers
all across the country to say yeah i
want this coveted thing to end
i want to get back to normal and the way
to do that
is to make sure everyone even that
crusty old uncle who resists or that
friend who's skeptical
encourage them convince them tell them
that they need to get to get vaccinated
because
this is how we get through it let's talk
about that because there's a lot of
canadians who are hesitating getting the
vaccination
you know there's not enough testing they
don't trust it
what do you say to those people who are
skeptical about the vaccination
it's interesting because a lot of the
people who are
most skeptical about the vaccination are
also the people
who are sort of most resistant
to uh the restrictions and and and the
things that have modified and got in the
way of regular life
uh that we all want to get back to uh
and to highlight to
to people who who are sick and tired of
covet who are sick and tired of
uh having to wear masks or or being told
to wear masks
um getting the vaccination and making
sure that everyone gets the vaccination
is the way to get through it and we've
seen in some countries that
as you hit that sort of 50 60 there
starts to be a plateau or people sort of
say okay
i'm not sure about it well we've now
vaccinated millions upon millions of
canadians
uh and we need to power through to get
to above 75
vaccination if we're going to do that
everyone even the people who are
hesitant
need to get that and that's why we've
deployed um you know
proper in language communications for uh
for uh multi-ethnic communities who who
you know may
just need to know more about it that's
why we're we've highlighted that every
vaccine approved in canada is safe
and effective uh and uh how it is the
path through this pandemic so i
understand people who don't like getting
needles uh that's
that's pretty universal but people would
really uh prefer less to get covet
would really prefer less to have to
continue to face lockdowns into the fall
and the way we avoid that is everyone
uh of all ages of all backgrounds to
just get that
shot so we can get through this how is
the rollout
on vaccinations in canada right now
because a lot of people feel that we
have been behind
for a while there um are you on track
now are we on track now
we are absolutely on track we we've
actually surpassed
the us in terms of daily doses now uh we
we are at the at the top of the g20 in
the top three countries in the g20 in
terms of
vaccination rates uh we will have enough
vaccination
enough doses in the country for everyone
to have had that first dose
uh by the beginning of summer probably
by canada day
and enough vaccines coming to make sure
that everyone will get their
full vaccination of two doses uh by
september
in time for for getting back to fall but
of course
uh we're not forcing people to do it
we're just encouraging them to do it
because
we don't get through this if they don't
do it so uh we're we're continuing to
work
really really hard to bring in more
vaccines
more quickly so we can get canadians
vaccinated
and quickly pivot to helping people
around the world get vaccinated so we
can all get back to normal and start
traveling again
but it starts with everyone doing their
part and what we've seen
over the past year has been canadians
stepping up to do their part
and i know we're going to keep getting
vaccinated you know at this time
being parents being home there's been a
silver lining where we got to spend more
time with our kids but it's also
an a chance to kind of reflect on
ourselves and reassess ourselves and be
a little bit more still
what have you learned about yourself
through this process
and what are you taking forward as a
leader for our country
i think first of all um i think a lot of
parents
have discovered uh how nice it is to be
home all the time i mean this this job i
have
kept me across the country meeting
canadians and doing it through zoom just
isn't the same but you know we do what
we can
um but it means i have spent more time
with my kids
much to my teenagers chagrins but but
more
time and quality time as a family unit
doing
puzzles and lego and playing board games
and things
uh then then we had in years and that
that is something to cherish and to
remember going forward i know a lot of
people
are gonna wanna once we're through this
pandemic to try and forget all about it
as much as we can and
yes there's lots of things we're going
to want to forget but some of those
things
we should remember and learn about
themselves like i i really learned
uh that uh that i am a bit more of an
introvert
that uh that i don't need as many people
and i'm happy with a good book which is
sometimes tough on my family that is a
little more extroverted
uh because i will close in but i've
learned how to be a a friendly
extrovert to be uh to be a better
politician
but i'm perfectly happy on my own with a
good book and sometimes being closed in
uh in a house with the people i love the
most in the world i just want to
lock the door to my office and and be
really quiet for a while
we're all learning different things
about ourselves i think as
as as a leader though um the the
the ability of our institutions to
respond
to support people was amazingly uh
important and foundational we're at a
time of a lot of mistrust of
of democracy of politicians of political
parties of institutions
uh we've seen a rise of populism around
the world and
to be able to demonstrate no you know
what we can get
a serb payment of 500 bucks a week out
to people
within a few weeks when something
happens like this we can be there to
support small businesses we can give
extra support to families extra support
to seniors
we can we can create national child care
which we're doing now
because it's not just the right thing to
do it's also the smart thing to do
these are the things that i think we
need to remember
we can do when we want to when we're
pushed to it when we need to and the
gaps
that this pandemic has shown whether
it's for for racialized canadians or
indigenous canadians or just
recognizing that this pandemic has been
harder on women
uh and caused a she session or rather
than just a regular economic recession
requires us to think differently about
what we do
to make canada even better going forward
i think those are the ways that
all of us have awakened a little bit and
has certainly accelerated my focus
on on bringing people together on
empowering the most vulnerable on
fighting
systemic discrimination and racism and
and really
looking at at how we can make canada
better from
from you know better fighting climate
change to
better inclusion of everyone to to you
know fighting against poverty and
homelessness these are the things that i
think have gotten more important for
everyone
you